all right I gotta I I do need to mention
this because this is the most important
story of the day and you know every day
I'm reminded that I am an old man and
I'm getting older and this is my
reminder for today
CNN has the report Global pop sensation
black pink have been chosen as time
magazines 2022 Entertainer of the Year
making the four woman band the second
K-pop artist to earn the title after BTS
in 2020
uh selected by YG Entertainment a big
South Korean label that screens
performers for Star Quality and trains
them intensively the quartet Jenny jissu
Lisa and Rose found International
stardom quickly after their 2016 debut
their first LP the album sold more than
one million copies in less than a month
after 2020 release now I've honestly
never heard of this group um they are
entertainers of the Year Global
Sensations I've never heard of them I've
been deprived of this Sensational music
I'm pretty upset about that I got to be
honest they named their first album
album so that shows you these girls are
creative Geniuses and I'd like to learn
more about them learn more about these
artists so I thought that we could
together listen to what is I guess their
biggest uh hit to this point it's called
pink venom so black pink pink venom they
certainly seem to enjoy the color pink
what else do they have to say
now you're really hoping that we could
listen to some and we are let's listen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
wow
extraordinary I mean extraordinary just
extraordinary
listen to these lyrics black pink black
pink black pink black pink kick in the
door waving the cocoa I talked that talk
run away as I walk
one by one then two by two makes no
sense you couldn't get a dollar out of
me
look what you made us do
this that pink venom this that pink
venom
this that pink venom straight to your
Dome like whoa whoa whoa straight to
your Dome like ah ah
that's poetry that's what that is I mean
this is poetry in our culture it's the
best we can do and maybe that causes you
to fall into Despair and wish you were
never born maybe it makes death by wood
chipper seem almost appealing by
comparison maybe or maybe you're like me
and you listen to the words and you hear
the deeper meaning
like they say they say black pink black
pink black pink black pink what does
that mean it's their group name right so
they are they're announcing themselves
they're boldly announcing proclaiming
their existence their selfhood their
standing staring into the void saying I
am here I exist as a very existential
way to begin the song and then they say
kick in the door waving the Coco what
does that mean
there are multiple interpretations for
every every verse in this case what are
they waving Coco hot cocoa why would
they wave hot cocoa wouldn't that cause
Burns
that's the point how Coco brings Joy can
also
burn you it's sweet it's hot it's
scalding isn't life like that I mean
isn't is not life itself a battle
between
joy and tragedy
is it a battle or is it a game an
interplay a dance
that's the question that they're asking
I want you to think about one other line
because this is the best they say
straight to your Dome like whoa whoa
whoa
what is straight to your Dome
what is it well it's whoa whoa whoa what
does that mean it's impossible to say
why because in modern culture we're
constantly bombarded by information by
Noise by messages light sound right
whoa whoa whoa it's a lot to take in
all of this is straight to your Dome
my Dome the domes of the world
what do you do with it how do you make
sense of it what's the answer blackpink
doesn't have an answer because life is
not about finding
the answer it's about
inhabiting the moment for all its pain
and joy that it might bring
that's what I took out of that song Just
insightful beautiful playful yet tragic
a masterpiece
they are the entertainers
of the year and deservedly so
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not we'll
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]